Cameron is such an incredible force and
she has done so much uh in in this
business we had to be very Innovative in
how we you know brought it back oh yeah
Cameron Diaz is back in action with
Jamie Foxx literally yeah I guess you
could say that after coming out of
retirement last June the actress was
spotted on set of her upcoming Netflix
rom-com back in Action that's Cam in
London with her co-star Jamie both
dressed to the nines during a night
shoot we love her so it was literally
do you want to have some fun just just
have some fun and I think uh that's what
brought her to it to convince Cameron to
get back into acting Jamie had to get
creative hello Cameron what up
thanks for calling I'm so anxious right
now I'm like I'm in the room how do you
feel though I'm so excited but I don't
know how to do this you know yeah it
started out as a friendly chat but then
Jamie pulled a power move and patched in
none other than Tom Brady another famous
person who retired but then unretired
I'm talking to Jamie
um he said you need a few tips on how to
unretire It's relatively successful at
unretired honestly exactly what I needed
I take my job very seriously Cameron a
goat in her own right in Hollywood got
her breakout moment in the 1994 film The
Mask alongside Jim Carrey this is where
the Whirlwind happens everything happens
at once here in the casino we have a
shootout a dancing
a hot number singing that I'm I do
myself
[Music]
as long as I get something from acting
then I'll do it fast forward 20 years
and over 55 film credits later Cameron
quietly stepped away from the spotlight
she married rocker Benji Madden in 2015
and they welcomed a baby girl Radix in
2019. she told Kelly Clarkson why she
needed to take a break from the
professional to focus on the personal I
think it goes back to all the things
that are like the P the big pieces of my
life that I had sort of lost touch with
just because you're you are completely
consumed by the work you know and on
Films is 12-hour days so it was a kind
of a reclaiming of my of myself for
myself well it seems Cam's return to
acting is a full circle moment her last
flick was the 2014 Annie remake which
she starred in with Jamie hey Mr will
Stacks or should I say soon to be Mr
Mayor no thank you we're just waiting on
someone that was the last film I did and
I was very much like I'm that's it for
me I'm done and I was really I am like
I'm done as for what made Cameron say
yes to back in action the love and
support from her family it just turned
out that
you know at this point in time it's a
really nice thing for my family my
husband is really revenge is the best
he's like so supportive and he really
wants to you know help me he's been
building his businesses for the last
eight years and he really wants to be
able to show me that support so he's
going to come along with our you know
our daughter and we're gonna all go
together make a movie and
[Applause]
for you
[Music]